[Music]
hello and welcome to day of the devs a
digital showcase of the best of
independent games
brought to you by double fine and i am
8bit we've been putting on the show for
nine years
uh believe it or not usually in person
here in san francisco where people can
come for free and meet developers and
play great games
and listen to music and have a great
time together and we can't wait to get
back to that but until we can we're
going to
still keep bringing games to you so you
can check them out
via this magical digital medium that we
have here we put out the call for
submissions and people from around the
world sit to their games and in fact
this year was a record number of
submissions so
yeah the devs is bigger than ever and
the games are really really really good
and we picked the best ones to show you
uh here today i want to thank our
generous sponsors
for their contributions because we
really couldn't have done this without
their help so thanks to them
i always get so inspired when i see this
collection of games because the talent
and inspiration and creativity on
display
just makes me really excited to be part
of this art form and industry
both to make games and to play them and
i just feel really excited afterwards so
i hope
you do too so please enjoy day of the
devs
so you all probably know axiom verge
it's very popular metroidvania came out
now six years ago believe it or not uh
and ever since tom happ the original
creator has been working on a sequel
which we're about to show you here
i think you'll be surprised and excited
if you're a fan of the original he's
doing some interesting new things here
so
please enjoy
[Music]
so
hello i'm tom happ i'm really excited to
share with you
some new details about axiom verge 2.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
axiom verge 2 plays a bit different from
the original game
whereas the main character trace used a
projectile based weapon in the first
game
indra's combat style is primarily melee
[Music]
but brute strength isn't inverse primary
weapon
it is a contest of mind over matter
brains over brawn
kendra's ability to hack enemies and
alter their behavior
gives her a strong advantage no matter
how formidable
the enemy
in axiom verge 2 it will be possible to
complete the game without fighting any
of the bosses
i've talked to many people who love
exploring the world of sudra in axiom
verge
only to get stuck at a boss they just
couldn't get past
and that ended the game experience for
them
[Music]
for players out there who love a good
boss fight they're there
and will be rewarded for your efforts
but if you prefer to run right past them
and keep exploring
that's a completely valid way of
experiencing axiom birge 2.
axiom verge 2 will be here before you
know it and i'm looking forward to
seeing everyone discover
all of the mysteries it has to offer
oh and one more thing
in addition to pc and switch we're
excited to announce
axiom verge 2 is also coming to
playstation 4
and 5.
i just can't even with this next game
it's so delightful it's purely in a game
brought to you by the gang at something
we made out of sweden
it's called toem it has the best art
style and is just
pure happiness try not to smile
hello hey son my name is nicholas and
i'm lucas
and we are something we made and we're
excited today to show our game
called tone
you play as an amateur photographer on a
journey to see the magical
phenomenon known as toem
[Music]
but first you need to get there by bus
and to earn your bus rides you need to
help the various quirky characters found
in the different regions
[Applause]
[Music]
the photographing guild will challenge
your photographic skills with specific
[Music]
challenges
as you stroll along various locales
you'll run into puzzles that will have
you using different tools
ah
[Music]
[Music]
oh
there's a lot to see and photograph in
[Music]
town
[Music]
and many friends to meet along the way
we ourselves are based in a super small
town called kaltsang
which is pretty calm and tranquil we
want to
try to capture that inside the game
to hopefully make you feel at peace and
content
while playing tom hopefully you have a
great time playing toem and we can't
wait to see your photos
[Music]
don't forget to wishlist on steam that
what he said
our next game pits you against your
friends to run the fastest time through
a series of dungeons
this is phantom abyss from team weeby
and devolver digital
hi i'm ben marin from team webby and i'm
the lead designer on phantom abyss
[Music]
good
in phantom abyss the goal is to grab a
relic buried deep within a procedurally
generated temple
however you only get one shot and if you
die you never get to try that tempo
again
phantom abyss is an asynchronous
multiplayer game where temples are
filled with the phantoms
previous players who tried a temple
before you and died
eventually when someone claims the relic
they'll seal off that temple
meaning only one person in the world
will ever beat a specific temple
[Music]
players are equipped with a whip which
they can use to climb obstacles
and interact with the world around them
phantoms also interact with the world
which can be used both to your advantage
and disadvantage so be careful
as players delve deeper into a temple
they become hunted
by that temple's guardian guardians are
incredibly powerful beings that will
stop at nothing
to prevent you from claiming iran
there are many different types of whips
that players can use in the game
which have their own strengths and
weaknesses you can also spend coins
during a run
to receive powerful blessings
the game's scheduled to be entering
early access on steam very soon
and i can't wait for everyone to enter
this world as i start making phantoms
and claiming ropes i hope you enjoy it
[Music]
our next title is a heartwarming tale of
fruits fungi and frogs
it's all about a little grape who is
tasked with caretaking their island home
and protecting it from invasive rot much
like my own gardening experience out
here
this is a game of questing combat
cultivation and building a community of
pals
this is garden story
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everyone my name's will lewis i'm a
co-founder of rose city games and we are
publishing garden story
garden story is being developed by our
friend pico graham
with music by our friend graham nesbit
[Music]
there's a lot to do in garden story it's
combat exploration
management
where you're constantly learning about
new characters and about parts of the
island that you're kind of helping put
back together
moving between the seasonal villages of
your island
you take on a lot of requests and
challenges to help your community and
discover a history
between characters and what's been going
on there recently
[Music]
there's this omnipresent mysterious
enemy called the rot that's been popping
up in force
and it's your job as the island's new
guardian to take it on
even though you are the youngest
greenling there
it's so fun to explore the really
charming and chill elements of the game
[Music]
[Applause]
there's really just a lot to discover a
lot of mystery mixed in with the
gameplay
and a lot of really great atmosphere
with how the art
and the music comes together
[Music]
the combination of some of garden
story's more classic game inspiration
with that
chilled out bright art and music style
is really special to us
it's really easy to jump in and feel
good about living in the world
the art and animation music and sound
effects bring something really really
new
while making sure that you are
comfortable in the game and feel right
at home
despite all the new challenges in front
of little guardian concord
we can't wait to see you in the grove
when garden story comes out
this summer
whether you've been trying to perfect
sourdough or just get through all the
piles of panic book pasta you've
accumulated
quite a few of us have spent a bit of
time in the kitchen this past year this
next game aims to take your real-life
cooking abilities to the next level
whether you're a seasoned chef or a
culinary catastrophe
it's a super chill cooking sim that
specifically explores the fascinating
world of philippine
korean and japanese cuisines sit back
and allow us to nourish your senses
this is soup pot i'm gwen foster from
chicken club and we're a collective of
game developers making a game called
[Music]
soup
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
soup is a chaotic and chill cooking
simulator
that allows players to discover more
than 100 different recipes
from different regions
all of which can be accessed in a social
media app called cookbook
[Music]
recipe take me back my energy
energy i cannot see i cannot see
[Music]
delicacy what makes our game unique is
that there are no fail states
we wanted players to be able to learn
and fail and have fun with cooking
cooking has always been part of many
games but has rarely been the central
mechanic
for soup pot we work with chefs and
cooks to make sure that the recipes
in game you could also make in real life
for the first time we are showing that
soup pot is just not limited to dishes
that can be made with cooking pots
you can also grill and skewer
[Music]
we love games like overcooked cooking
simulator
hotpot for one tenba muniglo bay
we hope that our game makes you love
cooking just as much as we do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
next game comes from glichi studio in
france this is a musical story it's a
beautiful adventure game that trades in
dialogue trees for
rhythm-based gameplay hello everyone
i'm shaw barda game designer and
co-composer at the french video game
company glitchy studio
and the game we're going to show you
today is called a musical story
did we make it
where am i
wait who am i
[Music]
am i dreaming
i can hear music
[Music]
yeah i know this this is my band this is
our music this was our dream
in a musical story you play music to
unlock memories
[Music]
the game is set against the 70s backdrop
with influences from
pink floyd led zeppelin or jimi hendrix
and tells the story of gabrielle
a young musician trying to come to terms
with his situation
through the connections to his musical
memory
gabrielle and his friends decide to
participate in the legendary
pinewood festival gabrielle will
experience
friendship love but also very hard times
as he struggles with addiction
the entire story is told without using a
single word
the gameplay is very different from any
musical game you know as there's no
visual playhead on screen
[Music]
everything is based on your ability to
listen to the music
and understand it making it a very
organic and rewarding experience
[Music]
we and our friends at the georgie have
put hearts and souls
searching for the best possible balance
between fun gameplay mechanics
and a meaningful and soulful story
we really hope you'll enjoy the game
when it releases later this year on
nintendo switch
playstation xbox ios and pc
and are super excited to tell you that a
free demo is available to download on
steam
right now have a good day everyone
video games are such a beautiful medium
because you can literally make them
out of anything developer kung orange
who made the criminally
underrated felix the reaper are back
with
a painstakingly nuanced and super hyper
detailed
stop-motion experience called
vocabulantis and while stop-motion is
nothing new to games
uh their pov and perspective here is
something really special and
it's still a few years out but we're
pretty pumped for it
my name is johan urzinger and i am the
stop-motion part of vocabularies
his stupid interjection army is
destroying for capulentus and my
speakers
what did my speakers
wait the elevator is coming
yes
i've made stop-motion since i was a
child and i do it professionally now
but ever since the neighborhood came out
in the 90s
i've dreamt of making a stop-motion
animated video game
but where you can control the characters
they can run and they can jump but they
can grab onto things
but then it's fully stop motion animated
where the
animator moves the puppet and you take a
photo and the animator moves the puppet
again
but to make it more interesting we do it
a little bit different
so the animator moves the puppet and we
take the photo
so as you can see each pose of the
puppet is
photographed several times with
different light directions
and out of them we can combine those
photos into a normal map
the character running around in the 3d
engine will have
light information based on real light
oh you decided to come back he's
a boy of no use
none of you speak i remember now
but listen then now i need your
there go help it
if you have any questions speak now
i thought
it really integrates into the the
handmade sets
that are photogrammetried in our
photogrammetry scanner over here
let me show you there is a motion
control
that controls the camera back there and
then the same motion control
controls the object and the camera back
there takes from each position of the
camera
around 100 photos the software turns it
into a
mesh and then we use that in the game
engine
we want it to look like a stop-motion
film but still we can
make all the levels fun to play and
interesting to play
thank you so much for checking vocab
lenses out i hope you liked what you see
we are looking forward to show you more
okay yes yes get up now
now show that you are worth some use at
[Music]
least
having been pretty much rooted to the
spot for over a year now the desire to
jump in the car
drive up into the sunset and never look
back is strong in all of us
this next game from the creator in the
car drive off into the sunset and
never look back is strong in all of us
this next game from the creator
six is a unique adventure that blends
procedural generation and narrative in a
way that has almost never been seen
you start playing as a teenager that
wants to escape its country in the brick
of turmoil
and reach the border which is thousands
of miles away in the mountains
as you try to get closer to the border
you will come across
different characters each of them with
their unique backgrounds
storylines and very strong personalities
[Music]
before we get much further i should let
you know that i have some
anger management issues now you know
so where are we headed today with happy
taxi
then just north it is now sit back and
enjoy your ride with happy taxi
by making those decisions along the way
you start tracing
your own path to the border and that
pass
will be different for each player
i saw you looking at my mags
[Music]
are you a fan of dinosaurs i won't get
angry if you aren't
why you will discover
personalities of this country
inhabitants
there are backgrounds there are secrets
they are trauma
and progressively by all the decisions
you may
even change their country guess who
forgot i had a god
now get in your filthy van and find me a
light
i'm mikey goodman i play jared
and many other characters on the road 96
i feel like having a smoke
a lot of bad things happened in his life
he's really bitter
and he's kind of taken his revenge out
on everyone else
depending on your tastes the destination
and most importantly the path to the
destination
will vary from thousands of
possibilities
they helped me played games with me they
stole my money
and they made me realize that i have to
come back home i have to make my own way
to help the brigades where am i
road 13 road 42 road 67
road 96
while it's still early developer strafan
has created something really special and
unique with the wandering village
on paper it's a town building sim you go
about your business
you build up your population erect
buildings mine for resources
but it has a really rad twist
hello everybody we're claudia beck hi
and philomena schwab
from stray phone studio and we're here
today to present to you our upcoming
game
the wandering village a city building
simulation game
on the back of a giant wandering
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
creature
[Music]
our studio is known for doing
science-based games and this one is
based in
biology and ecology
[Music]
visually the game is inspired by mobius
and
studio ghibli and musically it's
influenced by various forms of
folkloric music from all around the
world
[Music]
your people will be escaping and seeking
shelter from a toxic fungus
and they will find it on this giant
animal they call
umbu
traveling from biome to bayern bringing
new opportunities
but also new challenges
[Music]
[Applause]
and you're gonna be communicating with
the hambu to create
and build on your symbiotic relationship
if you build this specific building the
horn tower
near the animal's head so it will be
able to hear you you then get this
additional view of zooming out to the
animal and giving it different commands
such as run or lay down
[Music]
but the is still a wild creature and so
it may decide to list to you but
sometimes it won't depending on mood and
your relationship
with the animal we are big fans of city
builders and colony sim games in general
don't starve black and white the
settlers
rimworld and banished and all of them
inspired us
if i have to choose two games that are
most similar to ours
it would be frostpunk and airborne
kingdom
because they not only share our genre
but they also have a unique setting
and a limited building space
we're hoping to release the wandering
village on steam early access
later this year in q4 so if you liked
what you saw
please consider to leave us a wish list
and if you want to stay up to date with
the development of the game
come join us on discord thanks for your
attention
see you next time bye bye
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
next up is unbeatable from d cell games
just coming off a super successful
kickstarter campaign
uh oddly it's another beautiful
narrative
adventure game with rhythm mechanics but
much different uh than a musical story
so
please enjoy i'm andrew tsai i'm tj
maddox
i'm rachel lake i'm vasily nikolayev i'm
jeffrey
i'm r.j lake and we are your team
we're making unbeatable an anime
inspired rhythm adventure game where
music is illegal
and you do crimes
[Music]
the basic setup is simple you have two
buttons
one button for up and one button for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
down
that framework powers everything from
fighting off monsters during a rock
concert
to winning an eating competition to
playing darts
in between that you're going to be
exploring the city avoiding the
authorities talking to locals
finding hidden secrets and of course
planning out your illegal underground
concerts
in this early section of the game beat
that's the girl with think hair
and her three band mates have just
barely managed a daring escape from the
local police
[Music]
they find themselves washed up on a
beach on the outskirts of the city
and now need to scope out a venue and
figure out where they're going to lie
low and practice
before you go on for the big show you're
going to be finalizing the songs that
you're playing
the songs you have access to here are
all based on what beat in the band have
managed to write
which is influenced by all of your
decisions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
unbeatable is a synthesis of everything
we love about our favorite games with
the memories that we have
watching bootleg anime as kids with
unbeatable we're telling a
multi-generational story about nostalgia
and the ways that nostalgia objects
change when viewed with different
contexts
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we are enormously excited for everyone
to check it out when it's done
since there will be a bit why not
download our free demo unbeatable white
label right now
you can grab it on steam and itch and it
will let you play through a dozen songs
already
thank you from everybody at decel games
[Music]
so
our pals at devolver digital are back
with developer acid nerve for death's
door this is the team behind titan souls
so if you're a fan
of super challenging combat tight boss
battles
and birds with swords you're gonna dig
this one
hi i'm david fenn i'm a producer and
designer
at acid nerve and we're working on a
game called death's door
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's a fantasy action adventure set in a
strange world where nothing naturally
dies anymore
and this group of lazy office worker
crows are in charge of maintaining some
sense of order
[Music]
you play as one of the crows and your
job is to venture into the outside world
and reap the souls of the dead
[Music]
the combat focuses on intense fast-paced
brawls
where mistakes are punished and skill is
rewarded
our background is in tight 2d pixel art
action and we've been careful to
maintain the responsiveness of this file
the world is fully explorable and it's
entirely handcrafted
all of the characters and enemies that
you meet have memorable twisted designs
as well
[Music]
death's door has plenty of high octane
action
but it's equally about discovering the
secrets of its unique setting
and unraveling its mysterious story
[Music]
the structure and the scope of the
gameplay most closely match one of our
oldest inspirations
the legend of zelda
[Music]
foreign you have a grim job to do
but you'll also bring hope to the weird
and wonderful residents who are trying
to make their way in this strange place
the setting and the circumstances are
bleak but the moment-to-moment
interactions have touches of humor
and positivity
[Music]
it's this juxtaposition that we find so
compelling and we really hope that you
do as well
if so you can look forward to playing
death's door when it comes out
this summer thanks very much
[Music]
over the last generation of games we've
seen such crazy leaps in animation but
it's not just technology leading the
charge it's artistry
behind the frame is a perfect example of
that it's a narrative focused experience
from a developer out of taiwan called
silver lining studio
and it's got serious ghibli vibes also
rumor has it during play tests
it's been known to be a tear jerker
hey guys i'm origin len we are civil
lining studio located in taiwan
today we are going to show you a little
bit of our game behind the frame
uh
hmm
yeah behind the frame is a
puzzle-solving story orientated game
the story is about a painter who is
pursuing her lifelong dream to become a
professional artist all right
we really want to make the game feel
like anime film
so we use cell anime style to
differentiate new type of objects
from backgrounds
[Music]
the gameplay is in first person
perspective with several cutscenes
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
wow
[Music]
who she laid on will found out her
apartment have some secrets that she
didn't know of
hey
[Music]
um
like i mentioned before we want this
game to have anime and whimsical fields
so we chose hing ping 2d panorama
environments
instead of building a 3d model
[Music]
the story is really about love life and
how to preserve memories
[Music]
we are really excited to be part of date
of death thank you guys
we've always felt like the mission of
day the devs needed to extend beyond our
own bandwidth so we always take a turn
to spotlight organizations around the
world that are doing good by the gaming
community one of those
is ahsobu they're based in tokyo and
they're helping
indie devs in japan make their dream
projects come true
hi everyone my name is anne and i'm the
manager of asubu
a community hub for indie creators here
in tokyo
all about helping japanese cultures
we're trying to build a community where
they can learn from each other find
friends collaborators
promote their project by connecting them
with other awesome indie communities all
over the world
or athletes like today the day of the
dead
[Music]
but back to the end point on promoting
japanese indies here is a few games to
keep an eye on
[Music]
elac head is a unique 2d puzzle
platformer being solo developed by the
yoon creator namatakashi
[Music]
you play as a tiny robot trying to bring
back the light to the world
[Music]
electricity runs through everything you
[Music]
touch
including any place you toss your robot
[Music]
elect's head is due out on steam on each
io later this year
demolition robots kk put you in control
of your giant robot
how to make all the cash you can by
destroying as many buildings as possible
developed by takayaki tiju this is
multiplayer mayhem with a twist
[Music]
switch viewers can influence the game by
choosing items or actions on screen
[Music]
demolition robots kk is planned for pc
and console release later this year
[Music]
woke is a survival horror title from
casually games
inspired by influential games from the
playstation 1 era
wall takes place at dusk in an unnamed
japanese suburb
you control a defenseless cool girl
trying to return home before dark
[Music]
ashes pursued by mystery shadow creators
sesame games is planning to launch work
as a kickstarter later this year
and that's all for today thank you so
much though that they're firing us we're
big fans and it really means a lot to be
a part of this
if any of the stuff i talked about
sounds interesting please stop on our
asabu discord
or any of our events to check out and
say hi
on our website asobi.dev we are
launching a community profile section
where both foreign and domestic creators
and collaborators can use to find each
other
and please keep an eye on our next
assobundi showcase coming this september
hope to see you there on its surface our
next game is a serene slice of life
fishing rpg and a tranquil setting
1980s canada underneath the waves there
lies exciting adventure
exploration and angling jump on board
and join us on an epic voyage
and maybe you'll encounter the mystical
monsters of moon glow
hi i'm zach creative director and i'm
lou our director
and we're the co-founders of bunnyhug
with our lovely global team we're
working on our city's debut game mongolo
bay
a relaxing slice of life fishing rpg
based on a town
of people afraid to fish
[Music]
well guppy you did it your first catch
40 years and you still surprised me
i know this place seems strange a
fishing town afraid to fish
[Music]
but that's why our new venture might
just stay afloat
because all those stories about the
mystical monsters of moonglow
are exactly that stories
[Music]
mongolo bay is set along the eastern
canadian coastline during the 1980s
[Music]
we've always admired fishing in games
like harvest moon and legend of the
river king
however it's very rare to see that
feature as a core mechanic let alone
in an rpg
[Music]
so we've really wanted to capture the
magic of fishing in these games and
make it the heart of our game
[Music]
[Music]
as you catch and cook you'll be able to
sell a variety of recipes to upgrade
your shop
gear and fishing boat rebuilding the
economy of a town on the verge of
[Music]
bankruptcy
today we're excited to review the
aquarium
this is where you can donate preserve
and exhibit your fish
while being rewarded for your efforts
[Music]
your journey is split into five distinct
story arcs with a fully inhabited town
to traverse
and the potential for grand encounters
documenting over a hundred varied
aquatic species
all while uncovering the secrets of
mongol bay
we're also excited to share that in
addition to xbox consoles game pals and
steam
bay will be coming to epic game store
which you can wish list
now this bay is full of amazing new
creatures
waiting to be discovered so we'll find
them
and share them with the world together
as long as this book is by your side
so am i
welcome home
this next one mashes up a bunch of
genres in an unexpected way
but it's oh so satisfying it's called
loot river and it's from a studio called
straka out of slovakia
and they've taken super frenzied
roguelike action
procedural dungeon generation and even a
bit of tetris
and mush it all together in a pretty
[ __ ] cool way
hello everyone i'm miro from striker
studio imagine if diablo and tetris had
a baby
we're working on an island shifting
action roguelike
coming to xbox and pc loot river
[Music]
in loot river we wanted to create a game
about total player agency
with the ability to rearrange the world
you can overcome even the strongest foes
with each death you wake up in an
alternative reality
we are right now in the hub area that
you can fill with useful npcs as you
progress
the hub directly connects to the sunken
village
you traverse the area using wooden
platforms
that you can slide in any direction you
want
the platforms themselves are a handy
tool in combat
dodging the fast enemy attacks splitting
groups of enemies
or providing a hasty retreat
[Music]
here we have a chest i'd like to look
however these guys in group
would tear me to shreds instead
i'll make a path for them lure them out
circle back
and get my reward unharmed you can parry
most of the enemy attacks
and after you can counter them
enemies get stranger as you fight your
way through loot river
like a mage that can lock platforms
together preventing you from escaping
until you defeat it
the level design is procedural with
handcrafted elements
similar to dead cells or spelunky this
way
we ensure the levels feel intentional
and logical with a clear way
forward while also keeping every run
different
during your journey you'll encounter
many other travelers
some of them hostile but many still
friendly
you'll encounter merchants or aspiring
artists
or perhaps vendors who can join your
group and help you unlock permanent
upgrades
you'll encounter being so powerful your
entire existence is merely a small
annoyance
for them
[Music]
so i love when a game has an art style
that looks unlike anything else
that's definitely the case with this
next game it's from a small team in
ecuador
and really captures the sights and
sounds of the place well uh this is
despolote
hi my name is julian and i'm the main
developer of despalotte
alongside sevastian baldwin who is in
charge of the art and the music
the game is being produced by gabe
kuzillo and ian berman is in charge of
the sound
you play as a kid and you're sitting
around in school
just waiting for the day to be over
because you just want to play soccer
[Music]
foreign
it's 2001 and ecuador is on the verge of
qualifying to the world cup
they have never qualified to the world
cup before so it is a pretty big deal
and
everybody is anxiously awaiting the
final match
[Music]
the country was just coming out of this
big financial crisis
the idea of qualifying just gave a lot
of people a lot of hope
you don't really play a soccer match
because to be honest it's just way more
fun to kick it around
and annoy the people in the park
this park is inspired by a lot of the
parks i used to play in as a kid
like carolina
is full of characters just going about
their day
we really wanted to capture this
community of people and we thought that
having them improvised instead of
telling them what to say
just felt way more natural
they all react to the ball in unique
ways and sometimes this leads to a big
narrative moment
sebastian is doing an incredible job
handling all the characters
and modeling a city uh from pictures
from real pictures from places in quito
[Music]
a story about how soccer can impact a
place
and its culture
thank you i hope you enjoy it when we
finally release it
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have one last surprise it's from
developer variable state
best known for their game virginia but
with last stop they evolved their
narrative pedigree and take it into a
much more supernatural territory
it's published by annapurna interactive
and that's worth mentioning because
they've also been so kind to lend us a
sneak peek
at their upcoming annapurna interactive
showcase
which is chock full of freeze frame
moments so you won't want to blink
don't stop
this is crazy we need to move him
let's get him inside out of sight are
you a human being
like me come a little closer
you were made for each other i just want
my body back
so i feel like i haven't properly
explained this are you okay traveling to
the other side of the galaxy
i read the brief we're making history
here
resources technology culture this is the
next frontier
i'm counting on you now all right i'll
get the job done
dad this is not your fault if it's
anyone's it's mine
i think i've made a terrible mistake if
you want my help
you only have to ask i gave up
everything come on hughes this is it
don't you want to know what's on the
other side
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
and that's it thank you for joining us
for summer games fest and this day of
the devs developer showcase
see what i mean aren't you excited now
to go make games or play games or to
build a tree fort or something like it's
just so inspiring and thank you to all
the developers who submitted their games
if you're looking to submit one of your
awesome games for a future day of the
devs head on over to dayofthedevs.com
and sign up for our email list it's the
first place we spill the beans on call
for submissions no matter what time of
year it is
thanks to all of my co-hosts thanks to
im85 and
everybody who helped with the show thank
you as always for the generous support
from our partners
for making all of this possible we could
have not done this without you
playstation idea xbox nintendo
prime gaming and steam for the last nine
years you've been on our court
and we super appreciate it extra special
thanks to all the musicians who
performed or lent their flavors to this
broadcast you made it all the more
exciting and thrilling
we got luca and omniboy for we are ofk
we got the incomparable darren corbin
ashley barrett for yet again
performing at a day of the devs this
time from the super giant masterpiece
hades
we got the poet the legend dos one who
lent us his beats
yet again to round out the editorial of
this
thanks for watching until the next time
i hope we can see each other in person
and we got one more to close you
out ladies and gentlemen scientific
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
we wish
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one four eight one
one four eight one
one three eight three
one three eight three
seven two seven one
seven two seven one
seven two seven zero
seven two seven zero
[Music]
is it falling apart was it already
broken
[Music]
[Music]
sorry for the follow
[Music]
unfollow
[Music]
i just wanna dance
[Music]
you
i just wanna dance with you
[Music]
it's a bottomless pit if i stay
on the line took your critical hit
and i walked out of line no i'm not
coming back at least not for a while
cause we run out of lives we've been
running for miles
sorry for the follow
unfollow
every time i cancel time i can tell you
[Music]
i just wanna dance with you
every time i can't talk every time i
can't tell you
[Music]
i just wanna dance with you
[Music]
but you don't ever leave my head bet you
know then i'm still
crying better not better keep fighting
but i got gotta keep trying let it break
let it man slowly
give and take it a bit lonely wide awake
and still standing
on the verge of tears are dancing
on the verge of tears are dancing
on the verge of tears are dancing
on the verge of tears
[Music]
[Music]
i just wanna dance so i just wanna
dance with you
is it falling apart was it already
broken
am i back at the start can i let
all the hope in
[Music]
back
[Music]
farewell to
all the earthly remains
no burdens
no further dance to be
paid less
[Music]
is
in time
[Music]
goodbye to
all the plans that we
make no contracts
i am free to do
as i
[Music]
my old and warm
[Music]
safe from all
[Music]
hearts
[Music]
[Music]
to
farewell to
all the earthly remains
no burdens
no further dance to be
paid less
[Music]
inside
hello day of the devs 2021
i am daryn korb and this is ashley
barrett hello
and today we're going to sing some songs
for you from hades
the latest game from supergiant games
and
this is actually our i think it's my
fourth maybe our third time together
playing day of the devs
crazy so you know
nobody's keeping track but i'm pretty
sure that's a record for the most times
anybody's played day of the devs
i'm happy to be here albeit virtually
hopefully next year or the next time
it'll be
in person uh so i'm gonna do a little
magic trick right now
i'm going to tune my guitar just by
snapping my fingers
i'm going to snap and then my guitar
will be perfectly in tune for the next
song ready
here we go see now my guitar is in tune
and i can play the next song
perfect so that last song was called
good riddance
and this next song is called lament of
orpheus
you ready ashley ready darren okay let's
do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
[Music]
to see my love beside me
[Music]
upon me
that she may rise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the glass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
drowning
don't look bad
don't look back
don't look don't look
[Music]
all right thank you very much for having
us again day of the devs 2021 we're
happy to be here
and we just have one more song for you
all uh today
but uh hope you like it think you'll
like it it is uh also from hades but for
this one i'm gonna do an even more
impressive magic trick
where i'm going to snap my fingers and
then instead of a guitar i'll be holding
an entirely different instrument
i'll be holding a bazooky so here we go
ready
oh my goodness how did that happen
holding an entirely different instrument
now that's amazing okay this is our last
song
uh it's a pleasure to be able to play
for people albeit virtually
thank you for having us again uh and
we're gonna play
in the blood
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our lives
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
in your life
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
your dearest skin
[Music]
[Music]
it's in the blind
is
[Music]
it's in the blood
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
you